it's unfortunate but we are gonna be at
least 52 57 million students short in
terms of reaching that goal but for us
it's goes beyond just the number about
access if you actually extend that
number and think about the number of
children that are forced to apply to
secondary school that adds another 17
million then you actually look at
illiteracy rates around the world and if
you look at you know UN statistics
you're talking about 775 million young
people that cannot read or write mostly
women and girls then you tend to add
population growth dynamics in emerging
markets where and then the examples i've
always used are just look at Brazil
Russia India and China you would need to
add 10,000 schools every year just to
keep pace with the incremental
population growth so that isn't taking
into account the fact that a place like
India is short of 200,000 schools today
so obviously when you put all of those
numbers into context the scale of the
challenge that we're looking at extends
to well over a billion young people and
is accelerating away from us so the time
to act is now from our perspective what
you realize very very quickly is that
governments on their own cannot cater to
this requirement you know that the
voluntary sector of the NGO space on
their own cannot cater to their space
private sector on its own can't do this
either what we absolutely see is that
for us to address that the size of the
challenge you have to look at much more
collaborative powerful partnerships
between those three sectors in order to
address the challenge I think the scale
of the challenge essentially means that
we have to find rapid solutions to
scaling
a quality education so it isn't just
about access but it's about attainment
as well I think one of the things that
private sector with certainly the right
values and the right objectives does
have the incentive and the opportunity
to scale a sustainable solution at pace
but again private sector on its own will
only be able
to cater to one small component of the
demand I think governments and
especially what we would consider
governments that have the foresight and
the vision specifically to kind of throw
aside the old intellectual debates about
public versus private or just where the
voluntary sector gets involved they
actually have the ability to encourage
and nurture these powerful partnerships
so from our perspective private sector
on its own can't cater to this challenge
we do need the support of visionary
governments but actually the one group
that needs to perhaps do more is
actually industry and today if we think
about global aid there goes to various
initiative actually aid towards
education still represents a fraction so
six hundred million dollars only
globally and today when you address the
challenge that young people are not
coming out with the skills that they
need in order to be able to access
employment that is actually a challenge
that private sector with an industry
needs to pick up the reality is without
that support you were still going to
have a huge mismatch between the jobs
that are available and the jobs that
industry needs in order to drive
sustainable economic growth versus
actually the skills and and attributes
that our children come out
you